das weihnachts geschenk über das ich
mich als kind am meisten gefreut habe
war der game boy advance sp
denn meine eltern damals weihnachten
geschenkt als ich noch ein kleines kind
war zusammen mit den spielen super mario
bros und pokémon feuerrot und die das
gerät war einfach der hammer denn davor
habe ich die ganze zeit noch mit einem
gameboy advance rumgespielt
meine mama hat mir für den gamer und
waren sie damals extra eine kleine licht
halterung gebaut
die man oben dran krebsen konnte mit
tesafilm und dann hat man nicht auf den
dingen wenn der gamer dran hatte nicht
noch einen beleuchteten bildschirm das
heißt nachts damit spielen war einfach
nicht möglich aus diesem grund habe ich
die gelbe wand ist peter so krass
gefeiert also dieses gerät hier was
wirklich summe sondern hat keiner laptop
war also einerseits wurde der bildschirm
einfach beleuchtet und das war früher so
unfassbar krass und auf der anderen
seite konnte man einfach mit einer hand
spielen man konnte die mit einer hand
festhalten
die spiele waren legendär es gab
unzählige mario joschi spiele pokémon
selbst lege meine damen und herren habe
ich hier heute das ziel gesetzt einen
gameboy advance sp zu kaufen das ganze
ist allerdings gar nicht mal so einfach
und zwar habe ich vorhin schon beim
mediamarkt angerufen und der hat
natürlich kein demba ba war das ding die
über zehn jahre alte von daher habe ich
eine echte waffe beschrieben und habe
ihn gefragt he du kaufst du deine ganzen
retro games und konsolen immer und er
meinte bei retro spielen
köln das ist kein werbe video oder preis
und ich bekomme nichts umsonst aber es
scheint wohl ein cooler daten zu sagen
wir fahren jetzt mal zusammen mit dem
fahrrad zu retro spiel köln und schauen
ob die für mich einen gameboy advance sp
da haben mein kindheitstraum
[Applaus]
was hat ihn sind todes krasse tiere bei
jule retro spiel halo unfassbar krank
diese spielerischen 60p die ganze kiste
voll mit spielen und dem dieses ganze
budget einfach toll mitspielen die krank
ich habe nicht nur nachweisen gekauft
ich habe 300 euro hilfen
als ich in dem ladenbau und die wirklich
jedes einzelne spiel hatten jeder
einzelne konsole dies irgendwie je gab
übrigens der laden hammer und der typ
omega netter mensch als wir beide dann
im laden waren meint yu na dann auch
noch so war aus kupfer ds nintendo
konsolen dann habe ich jetzt
letztendlich glaube ich zwei ds eigen
kauft ein game assistieren noch fünf
spiele
also wir fahren jetzt nach hause hört
man dann zeige ich euch das handy wieder
zu hause
was kannst du eigentlich hier sind
wieder zu hause angekommen freunde und
mit uns diese ganzen dinge die wir
gerade sieht man schon dass alles
gekauft und ich hab's doch ich schon
gesagt hätte drauf ich bin jetzt der
kammer zurück auf die große kämpfe
zwischen als der tod auf jeden fall
nochmal um einiges besser können dass
sie sind jetzt die ganzen produkte die
wir gekauft jude was sag ich mal mit uns
willkommen
wir sind auf jeden fall angekommen in
diesem retro spiele laden und ich habe
sie natürlich direkt nachgefragt hay
habe den gamer brandt spd
nein einfach gesagt nein und hat er mit
meine kompletten träume und auch dieses
video den tisch doch dann habe ich
nachgefragt habt ihr denn gar kein game
one system werde also auch nicht
entgegen gebrauchten oder so näher
meinte nehme habe nun keinen gebrauch
mehr da hat er allerdings doch da und
dann kam etwas was ich irgendwie sehr
komisch fand und zwar obwohl der
eigentlich macht doch sinn da standen
dann halt diese ganzen alten
spielekonsolen die er da irgendwo
herumstehen hatte also ein gameboy color
an gameone ganz normalen hat ja auch
noch da und damit stand auch unter
anderem dieser dfv und der gamer brands
ist
und da meinte er nur der geometrie
kostet 100 euro oder so doch mit 29 euro
und welche kostete 30 euro also ein
gerät was die spieler auch spielen kann
und zwei bildschirme rad und neuer alles
kostet 100 euro mehr als dieses produkt
natürlich kann der gamer auch noch so
ganz alte gamer spiele ist es glaube ich
an alle leute die sich damit nicht
ausgehändigt habe mich gerade überhaupt
keinen plan was ich bin luca high und
ich mag dieses gerät ich kann euch auch
noch mal über jedes gewicht einige
bilder einsenden die ich in der
zwischenzeit noch gefunden habe sie mir
meine mutter noch geschickt hat wo ich
auch am zug nummer früher also ich habe
auf jeden fall eine lange geschichte
dahingehend aber dann habe ich mir
gesagt okay auch wenn der 130 euro
kostet die verpackung in die straßen
keine auch wieder als ladekabel aber ich
habe ihn trotzdem gekauft ich habe ihn
gekauft freunde sind
das ist mein kindheitstraum wunsch der
typ hat diesen gamer erwarten ist er
halt irgendwo aus dem lager heraus
gekramt der war noch so ein bisschen an
und dann die ganze zeit weil er dann
wirklich eine stunde lang wie im laden
mehr wäre auch viele andere sachen
gekauft und ich wirklich noch zeigen
werde da passt ein kleiner junge hat die
ganze zeit damit diesem ding gespielt
bis er alle last du also dieses gerät
habe ich mir jetzt auf jeden fall
gekauft ein früherer schwarze fand ich
auch echt hammer ich finde noch in
schwarz besser war silvias halt mehr so
ausgelassen haben wir uns auf jeden fall
den kauf bzw
sie haben wir einen tag im bett der
mitmenschen nicht gesehen ziemlich
abstoßend und dazu habe ich mir noch
zwei spiele gekauft und wollte
eigentlich feuerrot kaufen das hatten
die nicht einem deswegen habe ich
pokémon saphir mir auf jeden fall
gekauft und super mario world das spiel
nicht der film weil es gibt keinen film
dazu
was also diese beiden spiele pokémon
nutzbar machen ich will für den gelben
sack gekauft und dann habe ich halt
wahrscheinlich ein beide spieler konnten
sind wir aber auf jeden fall an dem ds
regal her gegangen und haben gesehen ok
da gibt es nintendos sogar pokémon
mystery dungeon da gibt's professor
layton da gibt's alles mögliche deswegen
habe ich zwei nintendo ds teil gekauft
weil die haben 30 euro gekostet und
einer rezession oder die opening druck
haben will
haben wir noch dieses labrador spiel
gekauft es ist halt echt heftig früher
hat man für die beiden sachen nämlich
zwei augen mit zwei leuten spielen wenn
wir dabei den bund-future golden
retriever allerdings hatten die das
golden retriever spielen nicht aber ich
glaube aber dort auch okay da ist auch
ein schieber ihm dabei die sind
eigentlich ganz süß m und dann hab ich
mir noch als spieler gekauft hofmann
mystery dungeon team blau im land
pokémon goldene edition und ich glaube
dass die goldene heart gold edition
tatsächlich die seltenste pokémon
edition ist für die erstmals der
unterhalt der uns sogar noch doktor
kawashimas gehirn-jogging dazu gegeben
ich dachte einfach juli gesehen und sie
braucht sowas berlin ecke die spiele
haben uns auf jeden fall gegönnt und
dann haben wir hier sonst nur noch die
ladekabel für die geräte ich habe mir
natürlich seien die jetzt eingekauft
habe ich schon gesagt habe ich die
spieler auch noch spielen kann und das
sind meine zwei finger ich würde sagen
meine damen und herren dass wir jetzt
allerdings bei diesem game boy advance
sp an eine steckdose anschließen mal
schauen wer fertig geladen ist und dann
gucken wir mal ob das ding überhaupt
funktioniert drei wochen später ich habe
das ding jetzt einfach mal drei wochen
laden lassen freunde
das heißt dieses nur aus der steckdose
aus das stellte jetzt einfach mal dass
ein wild studie rein und ich komme erst
mal ein bisschen näher heran ich weiß
dass hier vorne ist er an der seite ist
der amtierende seite durch jetzt einfach
mal
[Musik]
ja
ich finde dass er krank war ist so
einfach direkt im spiel drin es ist
einfach folge hat ich hätte das ist
direkt weg auf singleplayer es geht
alles so schnell weil es einfach nur ums
zocken geht nicht um irgendwelche sachen
und ein bisschen mit dem internet
verbunden dass auch cool ist ich war ja
onlinespiel über alles aber das hier ist
einfach back to the basics wie durch
jetzt einfach die ganze zeit in
deutschland
da war noch da hat einen wirklich er
dieses spiel war zusammen mit pokémon
früher mein leben freuen
deswegen bin ich so froh dass ich diesen
gamer jetzt so ich habe immer ganz
einfach so macht man ihn auszusagen und
sagen da will ich jetzt allerdings auch
das heutige video hier beenden
ich hab's einfach mega fasziniert mich
irgendwann mit dieser gedanke einfachen
wir noch mal so einen gegner erwartet
s&p zu kaufen ich da durch das schlagen
gerade irgendwie kaputt gemacht kommt
mir schon immer so weit nach hinten auf
jeden fall ein ganz ganz große sagen
euch fürs zuschauen ich hoffe ich habe
das video gefallen hat das getan hat
darf gerne einen daumenbruch da einen
dank an retro spiele ich habe die sachen
nicht umsonst bekomme ich hab den vollen
preis bezahlt aber es war es ist einfach
ein cooler laden deswegen falls ihr auch
meinen kölner seite und braucht sowas
haben könnte da gern mal vorbeischauen
und sonst habe ich noch eine ganz kurze
frage an euch und zwar wollte ich
demnächst mal ein paar mehr blogs wieder
machen auch wenn nicht so spannendes
gerade mal passiert an dem tag aber
vielleicht habt ihr ja trotzdem bock
drauf dann schreibt man flott in die
kommentare
ciao